le transport canadien consistera en un
tuba basse pression dans lequel
circulerait des capsules qui permettrait
de faire le trajet entre edmonton et
calgary dans l'ouest canadien en 20
minutes ou encore montréal et québec
dans l'est du pays
en vingt minutes toujours et pire encore
pour les compagnies aériennes
toronto montréal en 30 minutes seulement
parlé on a commencé le développement
industriel donc en fin d'année dernière
et donc on a trois à cinq ans de travail
pour amener sa maturité qu'on ne va
avoir un produit commercialisable pour
2020 sébastien gendron et président
directeur général de transport
j'ai un système qui permettrait aux
transports terrestres de passer en fait
d'aller de proposer la génération
suivante de transport terrestre quelque
chose que peu de gens savent c'est que
legault le gouvernement sud-coréen
développe cette technologie depuis 2011
l'ayant sont unanimes à dire
qu'aujourd'hui les trains à grande
vitesse qui existe en europe sont
limités à 300 km heure à cause de ces
physique la déliaison ou rails en fait
ne permet pas d'aller plus vite les
coups en fait acceptable si on va on
peut faire des pointes à 500 kilomètres
heure mais ça compte vraiment une
fortune et donc du coup il faut changer
un petit peu le mode de de la physique
autour de ce système là et le fait
d'avoir de recréer un environnement fait
sous vide pour s'affranchir des
frottements et d'utiliser des
technologies magnétique pour la
lévitation la propulsion donne des
perspectives en fait nouvelle même aux
constructeurs ont enduit un standard a
priori un attrait mag laisse tranquille
à lévitation magnétique pour éviter les
pertes par frottement des roues et donc
on peut avec regret c'est d'avoir des
trains qui vend des vitesses plus grand
que les trains c'est comme les fennecs
sirois et professeur au département de
génie électrique de l'école
polytechnique de montréal la lumière le
coup de midi maglev hormis lé coup c'est
certain que passer environ 500 550 km
c'est la friction de là qu'on peut pas
aller beaucoup plus vite que alors
maintenu nasri sont déroulés fusion de
l'un d'eux est là que lui vient un peu
dépassé cette limite la de la friction
de l'air à propos d'un système de train
qui est aussi dans l'alimentation des
technologiques n'ont pas été prouvées
autant que j'y étais j'ai pu classer
comme limité je vais par exemple donc
les normal qu'on les compagnies qui sont
les promoteurs de ces projets doivent
régler un certain nombre de projets de
maturité technologique en même temps que
le train et chacun y projette un peu au
projet l'objectif actuel pour transport
et d'avoir un modèle de travail d'ici
2020 a b c et d le directeur de la
recherche brian johnson à faire que tu
un spot veut se connecter à toutes les
grandes et canadiennes à grande vitesse
et sans turbulence vraiment technologies
nouvelles c'est vraiment faire
fonctionner ensemble et puis les aspects
pratiques là comment est-ce que comment
maintenir le rythme là le débit en
termes de nombre de capsules pour l'os x
temps mais le nombre de passagers
wiegele de personnes transportées il ya
informe de ce fait pratiquement depuis
son but nicolas sony est professeur
adjoint à l'école polytechnique de
montréal
l'idée c'est vraiment de sospel des
factures naturel en anglais des trains
qui seraient qui ferait dans le vide
complet
tout le problème est de maintenir le
vide et fabien effet extrêmement
difficile en termes énergétiques la
moindre petite fuite la moindre dernière
molécule des rebelles a retiré ses c'est
beaucoup trop coûteux en énergie
donc ça c'est pas c'est pas possible
d'autant plus sur la distance qu'il
propose c'est de diminuer la pression
la quantité d'air dans le tube pour
diminuer les frictions et donc la
résistance de l'air donc pour que le
coût de déplacer le corner énergétique
de déplacer les capsules soit soit
diminué donc j'allais pompe à différents
endroits dans le tube l'âme et donc
qu'ils cherchent comme ça reste de bon
point de compromis entre diminuer
suffisamment pour diminuer la friction
le frein et puis rester dans une marge
de fonctionnement pour ses pompes qui
est pas trop coûteux en énergie
un reportage de radio canada
international